hi
this is gonna be my second in these uh
political uh
uh videos uh triggered by the fact that
i had a comment from one of my viewers i
presume he's russian
uh with a lot of the usual criticism of
the west
uh and of course defense of the russian
actions uh surrounding the ukraine
and and also because of vladimir putin
had a very interesting three and a half
hour conversation with the russian
people today via television i had a look
at some of it
what i'm going to say about the
situation there is going to undoubtedly
reflect
you know my
prejudices it's going to reflect the
different sources of information that i
have other people start out with
different prejudices and have different
sources of information and will have
different perspectives and i think it's
always important that we have a great
mixture of different points of view and
we don't necessarily convince anyone but
looking at different perspectives forces
us to to think
uh
where should i start the um
yeah i think uh what we're dealing with
here
i mentioned in my previous video that
we're dealing with sort of competing
national identities
and so at the beginning
let's go back to kiev to the maidan
it seems to me that the maidan was
initially
largely peaceful
largely
sort of uh
call it the middle class or the
bourgeois class that
section of the ukrainian population that
wanted to live more like europeans
it was
initially not that large a scale
peaceful
uh and it grew
then on i think november the 30th or
something they were attacked quite
violently by the
ukrainian police and from that point on
things escalated
first of all in terms of size they then
attracted a much larger group of
ukrainians who weren't necessarily so
pro-european but were shocked by the
violence of the ukrainian police
viciously beating unarmed journalists
and students and and even women if i
remember correctly so at that point
violent elements call them the right
sector which is more of a of a almost a
parallel paramilitary organization came
to the fore and the maidan and the
confrontations between the police
and the uh
and the demonstrators grew more and more
violent also there were much larger
crowds from maybe 20 50 000 people grew
at one point
you know three four five hundred
thousand people who were protesting
largely on weekends against
the police brutality and people there
came from all over ukraine although
primarily from kiev and from western
ukraine
uh and this then eventually led to the
events of february 21st
when and the by that time the violence
had escalated there had been
you know vicious attacks by the more
violent people on the maidan against the
police the police had organized various
gangs of thugs who were kidnapping some
of the demonstrators hauling them out of
hospital taking them off torturing them
and he was a pretty vicious
confrontation confront which then uh
resulted in the sniper attacks of the
21st of february and uh i'm quite
convinced that once all the
investigation is done
and this will be passed over to the
gathered to some kind of an
international tribunal that that we will
see that in fact yanukovych and his
security apparatus
uh
basically gave the instructions for
these sniper attacks which killed
80 people uh innocent unarmed people
yes or in the course of the maidan and
the course of the violent confrontations
some 20-odd uh police were also killed
because there were some very violent
people on the side of the demonstrators
but that's not where it started
so
now
what happened then was that yanukovych
fled now he still controlled the
security apparatus he controlled the
army
i can't understand why from his
perspective
as the elected president why he didn't
go to maybe go to donetsk or go to hakov
where he felt more secure and then make
that sort of his center of operations to
try to win back
you know the country he didn't he fled
and it was subsequently discovered that
he had stolen billions of dollars from
ukraine he had these incredibly
luxurious houses in kiev and on the
crimean and so forth and so on and other
members of his entourage had behaved
similarly so yanukovych is now out he is
no longer he fled
his responsibilities he's no longer the
government
what's left
the parliament in ukraine the
parliamentarians voted in a new
government a new government which
included some people from the parties of
border which is a far-right party which
included i think one or two people from
the province from the right sector but
which was essentially the majority of
the people and the ones most active in
that government
are from the batishina or whatever it's
called fatherland party in other words
call them
uh liberal democratic type people that's
the case with yazinuk that's the case
with terchinoff uh that's the case with
one of their spokesmen
that's the case with with the foreign
minister and so forth and so on uh the
uh interior minister is a businessman
from harcouth
uh so that what then happened was the
russians and i think that putin felt
that things have got had gotten out of
his control from then on
everything in the ukraine was chaos
everything in ukraine where the
government was fascist banderazi
purchased whatever
in other words instead of saying here's
a government that is weak disorganized
interim trying to somehow keep this
country together until they can have a
another election
uh presidential election hopefully also
parliamentary parliamentary election so
that they can then
have people again choose whom they want
to govern their country the russians
chose not to do that the russians chose
to attack they attacked in terms of
propaganda they attacked in terms of
using their military although putin
initially denied it he said those are
not our soldiers but it was their
soldiers who helped organize
the takeover of crimea which was then
legitimized in a referendum a referendum
that was run
like no other referendum there was no
freedom of expression for both sides to
present their positions like we did in
quebec twice for a referendum very
strict uh rules about how much money
could be spent on advertising and who
could advertise
in crimea it was do you want the
fascists who are coming to get you
uh or do you want to improve your
pension and wage scale
and become a part of russia so i
quite willing to accept that a majority
of people in crimea were at that point
happy to join russia however not 97
because there is no question that you're
going to get 97 yes on and what the real
number is we simply don't know because
given that the russians were prepared to
force this thing through in 10 days not
change the question several times
not ensure that both sides had an equal
opportunity to present their views i
have no idea what other falsification
took place i do know that
on three separate occasions in two
previous years
uh opinion polls in crimea showed that
30 or 40 percent of the people were in
favor of joining russia i can imagine
that with their displeasure at the
government in kiev with the heavy
propaganda barrage from russia that
number would have gone
over 50
i also think that a majority of people
there probably
were more
concerned about their daily lives
standard of living security than they
were about whether they wave a russian
flag or a ukrainian flag so however
that's now water under the bridge and
then we see basically a repeat of that
scenario in the east in areas like in
the donbass region and elsewhere in
eastern and southern ukraine again
obviously
well-trained well-equipped army types
and then a collection of rag ragtag band
of local
god knows what types of people who have
now been given arms and are charging
around causing trouble
um
my own belief is that we will eventually
find out that
there were arms because where does all
where do all these arms come from all of
a sudden how come all these supposedly
supposedly normal citizens all of a
sudden
have arms that are out there you know
shooting off machine guns
there had to be some preparation some
training some irons were set aside some
people were organized and at the
appropriate moment with the appropriate
organization from russia this is my
belief i have no proof yet i suspect we
will find proof then this thing
was supposed to develop
so far my impression is
that the response of the people
in eastern southern ukraine probably has
disappointed russia because while there
has been a lot of support for these
column separatists it has not been
overwhelming
and um
i also suspect that uh in eastern and
southern ukraine from what i read
uh and what would seem normal to me it's
a poor area there's lots of people who
have
low wage jobs or no jobs
and that the main interest of the
majority of people is stability
security
the economy
and most people probably are not happy
to see people running around
uh with machine guns storming buildings
and causing this kind of trouble
so that
and maybe
maybe there are those who strongly want
to join russia maybe that's 20
i don't know maybe there are those who
strongly want to stay ukrainian for whom
that's important but i also suspect that
there's a large number of people who
really don't care and who would just
like to have peace and quiet and a
better standard of living
and i think that that you know i spoke
earlier about sort of competing
ideologies or competing national
identities
western ukraine has a very strong sense
of their uh ukrainian identity based in
their language and wanting to carve this
this strong national identity and base
it on the language the people in the
eastern and southern part of ukraine uh
whether they are ethnic russians or
ethnic ukrainians who culturally are
russians
they are more a part of the russian
world
uh culturally and i think their
loyalties are probably divided and maybe
flexible
and uh depending on so if they get a
strong propaganda barrage
from russia that'll
incline the one way and i also have the
impression
from watching shuster live that the
people in the western ukraine
uh have this somewhat condescending
attitude towards the people in the
eastern ukraine in fact the big
impression i get from watching
ukrainians on shuster live is the degree
of arrogance and lack of of um
i don't know sort of
mutually looking down on each other
uh between the two sides uh among some
like you can't generalize i think there
are strong ukrainian patriots in the
east there are people in the west who
make a special effort to speak russian
who want to you know
reach out to the people in the east but
then there are also those in the west
who say the people in the east are all
corrupt there's lots of sort of lumping
proletariat out there
you know and so we need to educate them
and bring them up to our level whereas
the people in the east say well you know
actually we like we enjoy being soviets
and we had a lot of advantages in the
old soviet union at least we had proper
education medical care and so forth now
we have all this uncertainty we have
these rich oligarchs meanwhile i've got
nothing
and you gotta you guys want to go off
and you to join europe we have no
interest in joining europe we're happy
with our identification with our russian
world
so there's this all of these competing
uh things
and um
it's almost as if you've got an east
east-west thing but you've also got a
sort of bourgeois
people who
you know like to dress well and and want
to be european versus the sort of basic
uh working-class type i mean even the
right sector which is a
you know ukrainian nationalist
organization they are also more of a
sort of a working-class uh type of
organization they're not keen on the
european union either so and it's of
course not obvious that your opinion
union being part of that is going to be
a benefit but now of course
ukraine the government is kind of
clinging to europe as as kind of a
counterbalance to the pressure from
russia so the whole thing is a bit of a
mess it's interesting in that regard to
look at uh putin's
um
uh
conversation with with the media
today where he's talking about this
russian spirit you know we russians he
says you know we have
you know we just had this influence of
so many different people so we have this
unique gene pool like he's talking about
as if some kind of genetic advantage
that russians have uh and of course we
are so much more spiritual so much more
generous because uh westerners they're
more calculating they're more
practical they're more money rubbing
they're more selfish but we russians
we're just more generous like in russia
to have a lot of money doesn't mean
anything and we have to give back well
of course the reality is quite different
the reality is that in western europe
they have societies which are far more
caring for the weak and and and the less
uh
uh you know advantage in their society
and also um you know charitable
donations and philanthropy is much more
developed whereas in fact in russia the
people behave quite selfishly those who
have the means to do so and there's an
absence of this uh social network and so
forth and so on and and it's funny too
because uh putin really
in other conversations that i've heard
he likes to identify russia more with
the sort of uh conservative values uh
which in a way are european more kind of
european conservative values before the
present sort of liberal tolerance
uh social welfare type of system that
that exists in
in uh western europe so
russians are more generous europeans are
more selfish but in fact if you look at
the reality in fact that doesn't really
relate to anything real
so lots of this sort of nationalist hype
and maybe putin needs it because
economically russia is going to be
facing some very hard times and so these
activities basically distract people
from the reality of their own situation
which in many ways is not much better
than it is in the ukraine better but in
many regions of russia not much better i
wanted to get back to some of the
because i got so much stuff by the way i
should say that uh you know i watch
telecom tv rain which is an excellent
excellent tv station prevents a lot of
information
it a lot of it as it on uh schuster live
is slanted
it's critical of the government and a
lot of things that they say are not true
so i don't have to
buy everything that they say but it is a
perspective and uh
similarly at ecommerce although echo
must be does have more
a greater variety of perspectives
um
for example on on uh schuster live
whenever they show a blogger from and tv
does to the same extent from donetsk or
from lugansk they'll always show someone
who basically is favorable to the care
position they won't show you a blogger
who is favorable to the pro-russian
position so i'm aware of that and so you
have to no matter what source of
information you you use you have to be a
little bit careful that you don't buy
the whole thing hook line and sinker in
that regard i'm posting a link
to a speech made by a russian professor
at
the leading sort of political relations
institute international relations
institute in russia where he talks about
how the government television in russia
is creating this reality for people
and a speech by him
uh is is very instructive because
there is freedom of speech in russia
telecom al dosh is a proof of the
freedom of speech in russia uh it is
occasionally encroached upon uh the
famous professor of the same university
who compared taking crimea with
sudetenland who was fired from his job
he was subsequently reinstated uh putin
at his uh conversation
said that he hopes that any undue
pressure on telekinetos on tv reign uh
you know will he's gonna make sure that
that there is nothing sort of
non-commercial that prevents them from
operating
so that uh
what happens in russia is that the
government has such a
quasi monopoly on television and on mass
media and that they control that so well
and they they create this reality so
well as is described by this professor
of course you have to understand russian
um
that they can afford to have these
people on the sidelines as a safety
valve
and
most russians don't they consider these
uh
traders fifth columnist whatever but it
does exist so that is encouraging
uh now
what happened was and yeah what else was
i gonna i'm gonna forget it all well
there's so many examples about the sir
putin and his mythical sense of russia's
uh you know uh special role and of
course they have appointed a minister of
culture there who is very heavy into
rewriting history uh
ribbon trump pact was a wonderful thing
and so there all of this stuff is
happening in russia and it's something
that i think needs to be followed
there's no question that russia has
created an anti-western feeling uh i saw
on one of alexey navalny's tweets a link
to a picture of the
train station in
somewhere in crimea sevastopol or i
don't know where and it has this great
big poster saying you know agents of
western influence and it had photographs
of people who presumably were
i don't know pro-kiev people i don't
know who they were but agents of western
influence right there on the train
station
but getting back to what triggered this
was this comment from one of my viewers
and he was saying you know the west is
encroaching on
uh so first thing is the west says
signed an agreement not to move
uh nato uh into eastern europe
all of my research shows that there was
a verbal agreement
between at the very least the german
foreign minister at the time in 1990 and
maybe baker the u.s secretary of state
when they were trying to get east
germany into nato there was a verbal
agreement that they wouldn't move east
so
there's no signed agreement but at that
time there was a verbal agreement so
obviously nato has gone back on that
tacit agreement
now
you can also argue that
i mean lots of agreements get broken
because politicians in order to get
something now will promise stuff and
when circumstances change
they kind of change
so similarly with with putin russia
signed
uh an agreement to respect the
territorial integrity of ukraine in
exchange for their nuclear weapons and
then he decided that there wasn't
convenient anymore so he no longer
respected the territorial integrity of
ukraine so there are examples but that's
one of the main things that sticks in
the cross my own view is
that
countries like latvia
poland
and lithuania estonia have every right
to feel threatened by possible
aggression from russia in one form or
another after what we've seen in ukraine
all the more so but the rhetoric from
russia has been that and
i i go back to
when i first started following ecommerce
back in 2008 just about the time of the
georgian russian conflict
uh
sacashvili
president of georgia
unleashed a sort of artillery barrage
on
the city the capital city of asset asset
had essentially been de facto
independent
since the early 90s and there has been
ongoing skirmishing between georgian
villages and setion villages in that
area
he unleashes a artillery barrage on
skin valley
and i read the rush like medvedev the
president of russia says
2 000 people killed this is our 9 11.
like this is like wow turmeric i'm
saying hold it now
100 people
um
oh you know what i'm gonna have to
finish this in a second video that's the
door
hi there yeah so i was talking about uh
of course ukraine and russian western
relations and relating back to 2008
when the uh georgian uh troops bombarded
the city of screen valley
as i said i don't remember 120 people
died obviously it was a a vicious attack
but it wasn't 2000 people it wasn't
genocide as they called it in russia
but it led to the russians invading
georgia and we had that short russian
georgian war
but uh that's when i became aware of the
extent to which
russian leaders and the russian media
will
distort the truth in order to
uh promote this this hysteria
nationalist hysteria internally
and
subsequent of course
that kind of thing has festered on and
and i couldn't help but think like what
did the russians do when when chechnya
had an independence movement i mean they
didn't kill 120 people they killed
tens and tens of thousands of people
uh so there's a bit of a double standard
here but this double standard is a
favorite theme amongst the russians so
the other favorite which this fellow
mentioned again and commenting was was
old kosovo
and the bombing of serbia
and uh
you know that uh why doesn't uh the rest
of the world recognize uh the
independence of abkhazia and the setia
whereas they reckon recognize the
independence of kosovo
uh okay
and of course then the nato bombarded
bomb serbia
uh first of all
the
um
whole kosovo thing needs to be looked at
within the context of the whole yugoslav
conflict which started in 1991 and i
don't disagree with those who say that
europe particularly the germans were
at fault in
encouraging slovenia initially and other
components of yugoslavia to
break away from the country by the same
token
milosevic was on a sort of a grand
serbian kick and so to him
gets back to this sort of competing
national identities again uh he had the
same arrogant attitude towards other
yugoslavs
uh as
we've seen in sort of the relationships
between the east some of the people in
the eastern and western ukraine there
wasn't an attempt there to
to uh
you know try to find common ground it
was more a sort of imposing
uh serbia
serbian uh uh rights and privileges over
kosovars and over croatians and so forth
and so on uh so as the country started
to break apart then it broke into into
uh uh you know croatia was gonna well
slovenia initially defended themselves
against the serbian army the croatians
uh and here again you know i mentioned
croatia
i was in a in a restaurant in the
interior of bc and there were some
people sitting there speaking the slavic
language and i asked them where they
were from and they said they were from
croatia
and croatia just declared itself
independent
and i always like to inform myself on
these things and i said oh that's
interesting and i said yeah croatia is
the best country in the world and stuff
and i said but 30 of the population of
croatia are served what is going to
happen to them and their response was
they will have to leave
wow
you know so that there is a degree of
intolerance in some of these
post so post-soviet or post-communist
countries where
national or nationalisms have been kept
under
kind of a lid and now it's like total
lack of tolerance now i'm not saying
that ukraine is like that i have the
impression it isn't but there are
elements of that there and and the hope
in ukraine is that the more
sober-minded people looking for common
ground will dominate unlike what
happened in
in
former yugoslavia but then
the whole kosovo situation
was one where the serbs felt that
because uh on uh krasnodar whatever it
was called the chornie of paulania or
something
in 1450
uh
this was a battlefield where lots of
serbs died fighting the ottoman turks
therefore
that whole area should be theirs
uh even the whole 70 or 80 of the
population was now albanian
and so their solution to that was ethnic
cleansing just as they had done
in bosnia so that by the time nato
uh acted in
yugoslavia and i'm
i don't know whether that was the right
thing to do or not but at least they had
this problem that
several tens of thousands of people
if not more had been killed raped uh
ethnically cleansed in bosnia and in
kosovo that every week thousands of
people were being displaced in kosovo by
the serbian army and
milosevic wouldn't back down so nato
bombed serbia net result was
550 people died 300 people
in kosovo 200 or so people in belgrade
most of the bombing was directed at
military or what were considered to be
strategic targets
including bridges for whatever reason
and uh but it's 550 people
i go back to
what the russians did
in chechnya so the russians get all bent
out of shape
over the bombing of serbia but i don't
hear so much about the bombing of grozny
for example
both unfortunate of course
then kosovo
kosovo was then declared independent
uh why not abhasi anasetya
personally for me i mean they've both
been virtually independent since the
early 90s
um
with all due respect to the georgians uh
i understand that uh when uh with the
breakup of the soviet union uh georgia
was pretty heavy-handed in their dealing
with the abkhazians and the ascetians so
um yeah i i
i don't think that they're uh that
they're going to get those territories
back anytime soon
uh
i don't know
so uh to that extent um if the world was
willing to recognize the independence of
kosovo uh why not uh recognize the
independence of those two countries uh i
guess you could argue that um i don't
know it's it's it's a moot point it's a
moot point
um
a little point what can you say
the other thing i'm trying to remember
the other
standard you know double
basically that's it i think i've covered
it there uh unfortunately i don't have a
picture of his uh all of his comments
um
so let me just finish off now with uh
getting back to ukraine
and the hysterical uh propaganda war
from russia claiming that the
horrible
banderazi
rightist fascist government of kiev is
using their military to suppress
peaceful demonstrators
in um
in the east and southern parts of
ukraine
in any country if you have people
grabbing seizing arms
or
wandering around with automatic weapons
seizing government buildings airports
the uh
forces of order
police or army are going to clamp down
uh
in some countries more strongly some
countries less strongly
in canada in the early 70s when we had
separatists uh bombing
mailboxes and kidnapping
diplomats and government uh officials
the government of the time pierre
trudeau
brought out the army
slam down
um
i mean i can only imagine in russia if
people were charging around seizing
government buildings and waiving some
foreign flag
they would be dealt with much much more
harshly than has been the case in
ukraine
and i think the government has not only
the right but the responsibility to
restore order so the whole suggestion
that somehow their the kia government is
acting
without mercy and so forth is just pure
nonsense in my opinion
uh what is true is that the threat of
russian invasion is real because putin
obtained permission from the duma to
invade
ukraine
a number of public opinion polls show
that there's wide support in russia for
invading ukraine
so that the ukrainians have every right
to feel concerned and therefore that has
definitely inhibited them in their
response
they probably should have acted more
firmly they are also inhibited by the
fact that the government kiev probably
doesn't have good control over their
police force or army
and so they've got to rebuild this after
after you know those uh
various security organizations uh many
of them are probably
loyal to yanukovych and or quite
ambivalent as to whether they want to be
ukrainian or russian so there's a real
problem there but the problem has not
been one of excessive use of force by
the kiev government but rather by their
inability both because of their own
division and ineptitude and because of
the pressure from russia their inability
to respond that way probably a lot of
the local people would like them to
respond because probably a majority of
the local people would like to see law
and order restored so there you have it
i just wanted to share with you some of
my thoughts on all of this uh it's
probably so long that most of you
haven't survived until the very bitter
end here and i look forward to your
comments and i will get back to talking
about language bye for now